[Musique]
mais si vraiment tu veux que ton corps
soit en pleine santé morges la raclette
récemment j'ai fait une raclette entre
potes et cerexhe opel un petit côté
bonne ambiance bon délire qui fait
plaisir à tout le monde sauf qu'à chaque
fois on y retrouve toujours exactement
la même chose il ya toujours ceux
conquis mais la poêle au dessus alors
que c'est fait pour les patates
ben quoi il ya toujours ce débat avec ou
sans croûte au wat
tu manges pas ta croûte panda je mange
que ça il ya toujours une embrouille sur
à qui appartient quoi attend ça c'est ma
pomme de terre
c'est à toulon les pommes de terre a
maintenant que c'est si j'avais réservé
il ya toujours une poêle perdu personne
c'est à qui allait tout seul c'est pas
moi non plus il ya toujours un mec qui
se prend pour un chef cuistot et puis
surtout il ya toujours gilles raclette
qui ramène sa science
alors ça en fait c'est pas de la vraie
la vraie raclée traditionnel smith ça en
2000 fromages qu'on racle d'où le nom
raclette ça vient de là dont on veut pas
alors ah bah si je veux quand même
ah bah non c'est pas traditionnel je
veux pas me patrice et manger saturés
alors déjà le principe de la raclette
c'est que ça se partage le faire tout
seul c'est un peu triste mais la vie
cette fois là bas elle avance que je
suis tout seul quand tu manges une
raclette physiquement tu es à ton pire
tu as la bouche luisant de gras
tallevende rempli thé rouge des bourgs
et tt depardieu quoi est ce vrai que la
raclette c'est un truc qu'on mange en
famille entre proches comme si c'était
la honte
je suis dépendant à raclette n'a pas été
suivi non ok squale mot de passe les
poêlons son show marchiche on s'est
battu contre m le matos à 6 mois
d'affinage et c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
la raclette c'est pas un plat normal
c'est clairement une orgie de bouffe
ultra caloriques pourtant on veut
toujours se donner un peu bonne
conscience c'est sérieux là alors toi tu
as en tête on a absolument rien à [ __ ]
quoi ma santé b je sais pas je poste
voilà c'est pas compliqué de manger un
peu équilibré quoi attention quand tu
manges une raclette vaut mieux être bien
placé sur la table parce que si tu es
trop près de la machine
si tu bois du vin bassa de vivre du vin
chaud à ton avant bras et carrément
carbonisé tel visage rouge écarlate et
la tête prête à exploser
t'as pas la clim l'avantagent avec la
raclette c'est que finalement tu es
invité il s'amuse à se faire à manger
eux-mêmes ans à ces pratiques par contre
après il s'amuse pas à faire la
vaisselle
ah ça c'est pour toi et la vaisselle et
le raclette c'est pas une simple
vaisselle c'est le chaos
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ça c'est ns est dr walid zone de
raquette le périmètre a été bouclé à
près de 3 kilomètres à la ronde
à cause de l'odeur de fromage et nos
meilleurs experts estiment les dégâts à
près de 3 jours de vaisselle
j'ai regardé ce que j'ai trouvé celle du
jambon exactement il est encore tiède
ah ouais ça au labo croire que le rien
la sphère de la fin du alors oui une
raquette ça dure toujours une éternité
il ya toujours deux personnes qui
veulent pas s'arrêter
ok je te lance de patates
tapez
ah oui ils sont fort en en plus le
lendemain à raclette et reste sourd du
fromage du coup pour le finir tu
rachètes des pommes de terre et de
charcuterie mais après et reste de la
charcuterie du coup pour la finir tu
rachètes des pommes de terre et du
fromage mais du coup après il tresse des
pommes de terre donc tu rachètes de la
charcuterie et du fromage et après tu
recommences plusieurs fois et après tu
meurs ou en fait finalement le seul
moyen d'être vraiment un terme à la
raclette basse et de faire ça à tanger
manger q25 plomb moi j'ai même pas
encore mal au ventre mais paris je
ressens même pas encore l'envi de péter
pour tout cas les gens qui aiment pas la
raclette
moi je trouve c'est un peu comme les
gens qui aiment pas game of thrones ça
les énerve que nous on aime
laissez-nous qui fait on vous a rien
fait même si on est d'accord que pour
avoir une parfaite santé
c'est quand même mieux de manger des
légumes de bord de l'eau de paris
clignoter entre les repas de faire du
sport au pub maire demande la raclette
vous êtes sur un téléphone alors appuyé
avec votre doigt sur ma grosse tête ici
pour vous abonner facilement et en fait
ça marche aussi depuis un ordi
alors elle est pas belle la vie ça